students phenomenally irritating but i
would question how much
power they have
in contrast to the things i find more
worrying than happening in the world
today right or even the professors right
even 20 year olds don't have that much
power but they're not 20 forever
10 years later they're 30. and 20 years
later they're 40. right and whatever
happens in the university happens
everywhere five years later and very
very sadly for people in my politics
left-wing politics what happens because
they get older is that they've
traditionally got more conservative
so i don't think you can make a case
that the the current where people are
they're like we want our money
so like what they're like half the 20
year old yeah we're keeping that
literally
so it's like what
is
today is actually going to be the
ideology that takes them all the way
through their life that's never been the
case
it'll be around long enough to do plenty
of damage like it already is okay but
even if we accept that students sorry i
know we just paused it what he just said
like we are
we are the product of people before us
voting and putting in these laws that
didn't think about the future they
thought about
what was good for them right then and
there and we
are not the product but the benefactors
of what happened way before we came and
so
now it's like
we have we have to think about that and
i feel like a lot of people don't think
about that when they vote and when they
vote on these laws vote on everything
and they just think about right now but
how is a law like this going to affect
someone in 10 years when they're able to
vote it's like the thing is you don't
think about how many consequences come
from a law and there's a lot of
consequences that people don't intend to
happen like the one i gave you earlier
yeah the the law that sounded good right
you even admitted it sounded good yeah
until the consequences these these kids
think they're stupid
yeah and it's stuff like that where like
it's like social security sounded good
are you getting social security
no probably not i don't know none of us
are we donate eight percent we basically
donate eight percent of our paychecks
you know that no you're on social
security it's like um basically they
didn't expect people to live as long as
they do
so like when i worked at a job i i was
making like i was like 50k
or no no no it's not a 401k it goes
towards it's like money that you get
when you're over a certain age from the
government okay yes people are living so
long like it sounded good oh okay we'll
take money every
like this percent of your paycheck and
when you're old you get it basically but
the problem is people are living
longer and longer and with more and more
medical issues so like we i would give
up i remember looking at my paycheck and
it was a couple thousand dollars it was
like i was making around 50k
and it was eight percent of that so
whatever that's like what 4k
because eight eight out of a hundred is
eight so half of that sport yeah four
thousand dollars
every year
they take out of your paycheck i will
never see it because they're it's gonna
run out like it's not sustainable
what do you mean it's gonna run out like
how is it gonna run off if you don't use
it this is okay this is something my dad
taught me and this this just made me a
conservative i'm just gonna warn you
this is how powerful it is
okay my dad
he looks at things as like he would tell
me it's like two dollars in one dollar
out so when you're looking at a program
you can only have so many programs where
you put two dollars into something
and you make one dollar off of it okay
because it's losing money does that make
sense because you're putting two dollars
and you're taking one dollar out and you
can like while these programs these free
like social programs they sound like
nice like social security welfare all
that stuff you can only have so many
so many before we run out of money
or what do they do they print more money
and what happens the value of the dollar
goes down yeah and that doesn't and then
you have people in the middle class
losing
money that they save their whole lives
and so it's like there's all these
repercussions about for for things that
sound good and sound nice
and it's the people and like on the
screen that'll say oh i'm helping these
people
but you're really taking away the middle
class
because you're taking away like their
money out of their like 50k right i come
from a good family so i i'm in a
different position but let's say i
wasn't let's say
sorry you know
yeah but like like you like they're
taking away that money from you yeah
instead and they're giving it to the
generation before you and you're never
gonna and like four four grand times ten
years and then on top of that the value
of the dollar is going down and the
people making the policies get to say oh
i'm helping people like jess but they're
not helping you
wow
isn't that crazy that's
wow
it red pills you a little bit oh my gosh
and their pomo professors are quite
annoying which i think is probably i
agree with something else they're not
just annoying like they're destroying
the universities and that's not a good
thing and they're particularly
destroying the social sciences and the
humanities the sciences are safe so far
but not for long because the scientists
in particular are terrible at politics
and the left-wing activists are great at
politics and so they'll win eventually
the national science foundation is
already introducing diversity
requirements for hiring in mathematics
and universities it's like good luck
with that that's not going to work there
are hardly any mathematical geniuses if
you start putting all sorts of arbitrary
restrictions on their hiring you're just
going to not and you're going to end up
not finding the ones that there are
so besides i don't think that's true
actually because if you say there are
very few mathematical genes
well
next year i'm going to be a fellow
oxford university so i spend time
talking to academics i've talked to a
lot of academics from my book i do agree
with you there is an illiberal strain
that is sweeping through a lot of
universities i don't think it's an
existential threat and i certainly don't
think it is to me the biggest issue in
world politics today it's the one that i
would choose personally what do you
think is the biggest issue i think that
the rise of strongmen authoritarians
around the world is very worrying and
that's one of the reasons i find the
subtitle of your book fascinating
because
it's called an antidote to chaos why
isn't it an antidote to order which you
also say in its excessive manifestations
is bad
i've said that
well you can't write a book about
everything no no but you've specifically
chosen antidote to chaos so why is chaos
300 lectures online and i talk plenty
about the pathology of order in those
lectures okay but i'm just a fan of
authoritarian strong men that's for sure
well that's good but i do think that the
way that you talk about order in the
book is something that people will take
away from it be specific okay so let me
think um the way that you hold them real
quick
and antidote is something to make
something better right
why is she upset that it's an antidote
to chaos essentially it would make
things better
they get mad over everything i literally
was like an antidote i was like antidote
helps it get better i was like am i do i
not know the correct definition
sometimes they use these big words i
mean i'd be having to think real hard
no the same i've been over here like i
don't want to seem dumb on camera no no
i've listened to a lot of him but when i
first started listening i would have to
google work yeah i'm gonna go home and
be like okay he said this now i know
you talk about natural dominance
hierarchies and lobsters let's get on to
the lobsters because i think that the
the thing that people take away from
that is
male lobsters compete for female
lobsters and that says something about
society now that's that men need to be
dominant in in society because if
lobsters do it then there is something
that we can read about humans there's
nothing in there wait let me let me it
is book he's a he's a social side so he
he gives examples that are sim like in
the book he talks about lobsters oh okay
okay because they're they're i forget
why and they call i'm sorry the comments
is gonna roast me today it's okay like
they're somewhat similar to humans and
the way their hierarchies are set up
like something okay she talks about it
so so she's saying like oh so you're
saying like we're like like since
lobsters do it we should do it but
that's no this is what the man studies
yeah okay i thought she was just pulling
something from thin air that's why i was
like
lobsters you're gonna lobster okay it
makes sense okay
chapter at all
that suggests that the way that men
should succeed in human hierarchies is a
consequence of the exercise of power
there's not one line in that entire book
that's that claims that because it's not
what i believe
most human hierarchies as i already
pointed out are hierarchies of
competence not power
okay so that's why we don't live in a
patriarchal tyranny and so if you want
to be a successful man then you should
be competent and that will move you up
the hierarchy and that will make you
attractive and for good reason unless
you want an incompetent mate which is
possible and and
and happens but isn't something that i
would recommend
people will sometimes choose an
incompetent mate because they're
intimidated by competence and so they'll
settle for someone who they don't
respect because they feel that they can
master them and they won't be
intimidated but it's not a recipe for a
happy life i can tell you that
so there isn't a line in that chapter
that talks about power as as as the
proper means of conducting yourself in
life there's not a line in the book and
there's nothing in anything i've ever
said that suggests that okay no i'm
saying but it's really important because
people have read this chapter and they
make exactly the argument that you make
and it's a misapprehension
so it's a misapprehension of the book
okay but if so many people are getting
the same misapprehension could it be
there are so many people that are
getting it there's two million people
that have bought the book and there's a
very small handful of people who have a
particular ideological perspective who
enjoyed developing that perspective
because it indicates just what sort of
reprehensible individual i am but it has
absolutely nothing to do with what i
wrote or what i've said or what i
believe
i don't believe that our fundamental
hierarchies are based on power i don't
believe that the way that you move up
our hierarchies is as a consequence of
manifesting power it's competence okay
my big problem with the lobsters is that
it's scientifically
bollocks
right it's just you cannot read across
from lobsters
he's like driving me [ __ ] he's like
all right bet come at me
of course you can that's why serotonin
works on lobsters but it works in two
different ways so if serotonin makes
lobsters more aggressive it makes you
makes them less aggressive
serotonin makes human beings more
dominant but less aggressive
and the only reason it makes them more
dominant is because they're less
irritable and they're less defensively
aggressive
so it's not bollocks i know my
neurochemistry so if you're going to
play neurochemistry let's go and do it
okay we'll use the antidepressants work
on lobsters yes they do we make a
lobster that's been defeated in a fight
more likely to fight again that's not
the same mechanism that happens in
humans because monsters don't get
depressed as the way that humans are i
think you're anthropomorphizing into a
ridiculous degree these are creatures
that urinate out of their faces i think
that uh the fundamental issue among um
knowledgeable
uh animal behaviorists is that
anthropomorphization with animals is
generally the appropriate tactic unless
you have reason to doubt it which is
because there's continuity between us
and animals rather than discontinuity
and the idea that the
anthropomorphization of animals is
inappropriate is something derived from
1950s behaviorism
the the highly trained affective
neuroscientists and people who study
motivation and emotion as well as
neurochemistry know perfectly well that
there is biological and behavioral
continuity across the animal kingdom and
way down into the kingdom as well which
is exactly why i chose lobsters to
indicate that there is so much
continuity in the systems that allow us
to estimate uh status position that we
share it with creatures that are a third
of a billion years old and the reason
that i made that argument was to put
paid at least into part in part to the
absurd marxist proposition that
hierarchical structures are a secondary
consequence of western civilization and
free market economies which is as
preposterous a perspective as you could
possibly develop about anything
hierarchies are a third of a billion
years old you can't blame them on the
west or men or capitalism and we're
wired for hierarchical perception in
ways that you can hardly possibly
imagine even our ability to rank order a
set of objects seems to be tightly
linked to our ability to assess the
relative status of people in our in our
social
milieus
do you understand what you just said
a little bit
like do you understand what he's saying
with like hierarchies being natural
kind of
so
because basically he's saying like even
lobsters have hierarchies and
hierarchies aren't necessarily a bad
thing
and so like in in our society like
like there's hierarchies in everything
there's hierarchies and looks yeah
there's hierarchies in um
in basketball there's higher like
there's just people that are better and
there's people that are worse
and so he's saying like even lobsters
have hierarchies of like competence all
right
don't don't quote me on the lobster
stuff but like do you know what i'm
saying so like she's trying to make it
seem
like it's oppressive and terrible but
he's saying no it's based on competence
okay does that make sense do you agree
with that or do you disagree
um
some
i would
yes i would agree on it um
i don't
i don't have like a reason it just it
just makes
sense um
but i
i under it's interesting to hear
him talk about like how humans and
animals like have
there's a lot of similarities between
humans and animals
and
the fact that she threw in like well
lobsters don't get depressed it's like
he's not talking about
depression he that's that's not
something that the test was done on
he was talking about serotonin and how
it has a similar effect on
humans and lobsters and that is why he
used the the example yeah and so
it's
it's interesting i'm like listening a
lot i'm like
that's what's good about because you
wouldn't really consider yourself like
you wouldn't consider yourself super
right
but you understand what he's saying yeah
for me if if it makes sense and i may
not have heard it before or
understand it
i'm not going to shoot it down
and
be like oh that's not right because i've
never heard that before and i don't
believe that if i don't believe it at
the end of the day and it doesn't make
sense to me i'm gonna be like okay
that's your beliefs i have my beliefs
but i'm not going to completely cancel
it because
as a as a human you're supposed to learn
every single day whether it's something
you believe or don't believe well
sometimes you don't know like sometimes
like
with new information like you can't
possibly this man knows more than all
ever oh yes of course and so why do
these girls try to debate him like they
look so dumb when his eyes got big and
he tilted his head
oh he's going to come for you
all right
so and the biochemistry is very very
similar and the reason we know that is
because most of the drugs that are used
on people are first tested on animals
now it's not often animals as primitive
as lobsters but it is plenty so a lot of
what we know about neurological
structure for example is a consequence
of studying the flat room worm which is
much more primitive organism than the
lobster continuity is the is the rule
okay so what can we learn from killer
whales that live in matriarchal pods
often led by uh
all right
wow a lot that was a lot a lot a lot
my goodness what'd you think
i'm starting to like jordan peterson
like i wanna i wanna just dive a little
bit more you're gonna binge him when
you're home oh goodness
i went on a crazy binge when i first
found him a couple years ago have you've
heard me say some of his points haven't
you yeah like in the last video i was
like that's where pearl gets that's
that's that's from yeah this isn't it's
not me
i literally thought you would be like
looking up stats i'm like pro knows her
stats no i do sometimes but it's like if
if a guy smarter than me says it like
you you'll double check right but like
why would i not i wouldn't exactly yeah
but i i like it i
am like getting nervous come like am i
going to become just a real pill person
i don't know are you going to become a
what just a redfield person i'm like
this is this is the surface too this
isn't even like this is i can't guys i
can't give her rolo yet
rolo tomasi is like
who we're going to end on
and that's like the deepest red pill so
yeah we're not this is where is it this
is the scratch where does kevin samuel
was following that um he's above rolo
you have to watch kevin before rolo um
he's
that's actually who we're going to react
to next i think okay
guys let us know in the comments who you
want us to react to next please